I've never heard a worst case of hiccups
in my life as soon as little Ellie was
resurrected it was a hiccup every fifty
seconds from you and you try to cover it
up and you would giggle a little
laughter them sometimes hi everyone
Tamra chambers
oh I'm Jake Jerry this is Tamra just saw
tonight we saw Pet Sematary yes
sometimes Dead is better I've only read
I think three or four of Stephen King
novels you are he's written a few more
than three or four yeah so you're like
an expert
I I don't know I am I am a constant
reader I have read many of the books
you're a fan I'm a big fan I am glad to
have you here because I know there are a
few changes I don't work just reread the
book fresh in my mind the first movie I
enjoyed but like you said it has a
reputation for a bit of cheese factor
like camp this has less of that yeah I I
gotta say overall feelings I felt like
there were some things to be improved
upon for sure I enjoy it though I
thought we're such in the age of
beautiful hoar I really enjoy be b-grade
the horror films but we're such in the
time of some really good horror being
made they're really beautiful maybe not
even good but like beautiful horror
being made sure that's really cool both
of those things are true beautiful and
good and what we're but we are in the
time of is horror making mainstream
money yeah which I am all about I love
that so we're gonna go to spoilers for
this there's no twist to the movie I
don't think no not unless you read the
book then no sudden there's a big twist
this movie is very different from the
book preface here's what the movie is
what you saw in the trailer it's about
this family who moves to this rural
it meant in me John Lithgow yeah shows
our main character I forget his name but
man do I have a fat crush on him my god
beautiful man oh yeah basic Clark what
is it isn't the chin I think it's the
rugged beard okay
my so you're like like in mourning once
he's in mourning you're like oh there he
is
I also don't necessarily think he's
fantastic in this role no no I think he
was my least favorite character but he's
fine
I think he did well but I think also I
think filmmakers who I'm fans of the two
drew the guys who directed this they
directed a indie horror movie called
starry eyes that was on Netflix for a
while tell me about this yeah that movie
I would do swear we don't swear which
way that movie so I was like these guys
are gnarly they're gonna go for it
because Pet Sematary is the darkest of
Kings books okay and not in like what we
think of as horror right now which is
like jump scare jump scare jump scare
but in like an examination of death and
explaining death to children and then
losing people losing children you know
like in the book spoilers time yes in
the book it's not Ellie who dies it's
gage and gage is a toddler he's this
little toddler who gets smeared by a
truck you know and then he was adorable
he was lovely he'd never did a thing in
his life innocent little kid yeah it's
so emotional in the book yeah and they
don't shy away from it like they do in
the movie Ellie gets smeared by the
truck right don't show me her body
because she was spotless when he's going
over her like if her hair is not a
matted bloody mess yeah then you are
taking me out of it yeah so here's the
thing I want to say in high school I
literally got hit by a car oh Jesus I'm
so sorry okay but like that really took
me out of it
seeing her body because I got
by like a Prius it was a mess so like
seeing her small like six-year-old not
ruin nice by this you're gonna birth the
number she wasn't sick she's so small to
see her not ruined by a semi-truck yeah
yeah it was this around a wrinkle a
right or Rinku truck and so it has this
huge like what would carry fluid yeah
like yes I you know whenever that pops
off the truck and over yeah yeah yeah no
not believable he was coming around the
truck and I was like they can really do
this like even if there's just grass
dripping blood don't show me the body
ultra music later his wife is holding
that doll and it's got blood on its
dress just show me a doll with blood on
its dress I'm feeling it yeah but he
goes over to her and she's spotless yeah
they've done pretty well through the
movie kind of building who the family
was introducing us to the cemetery and
the cemetery beyond the cemetery was the
introduction but at that point they just
started dropping beats I liked a lot of
the changes that they made yeah it's a
very effective sequencing Zelda is the
sister yeah she was more effective in
the cheesy movie really the dumb waiter
thing is invented for this this is
brand-new so okay I was gonna say I love
in what is haunting of Hill House in
that makes the dumbwaiter see what's
there
which ones that one oh yeah I wanted it
to be that and then it wasn't that it's
a hell of a dumbwaiter sequence in
Halloween h2o as well by the way
oh I saw it because you were talking
about so much it's my favorite one John
Crandall in the novel is the loveliest
man well you and you get the feeling
that he is you want to just love him and
I love him I love yeah yeah but it felt
like they played him more creepy Jason
Clark I recognized him but not from oh
Terminator Genisys I saw that okay dark
thirty oh that's what I that's what I
recognized his face from oh is there
cemetary I saw that one Oh
Winchester ah damn was it good else I
think he's really good I think the whole
cast is really good I I really don't
like talking um poorly about actresses
okay I'm getting that vibe on you know
I'm feeling like you're being a little
generous here I did not enjoy him in
this I think there were so much
potential there and I think it was so
surface-level hmm I think he had so much
written to feel such depth and be
written to have so much depth and
clearly he was in the book and in this I
just do not feel like he was well here's
part of the problem too is that once
they got into like the book really
explores the direct aftermath to tragedy
yeah you know and that is part of what
horror is great about is like you feel
like you're getting inoculated against
something that's going to happen it's
like a vaccine for life right yeah like
you get a shot of horror and you're like
I'm a little bit of prepared for when
something horrible happens to me yeah
yeah yeah and Pet Sematary the book was
that all about loss and grief but in the
movie it's like she's down on the side
of the road oh she did her confidence
being lowered on the ground uh and
that's part of the to our format this
crap but like during the movie out the
whole time I was whispering to myself
I'm sure you heard something right
they're like no no no no no no I didn't
like not enjoy this like we just were
talking about Winchester this was not a
Winchester situation I did enjoy this
movie I just when you see something as
well done is this like I think it was
really pretty to watch
I think the cast was awesome I think it
was done well it has obviously good
really good source material I think you
just see something like that near like
oh I want to talk about what can be
improved yeah you like mid there missed
opportunities yeah yeah and you just
feel them kind of passing you by I
should be feeling more right now yeah
and it has mostly to do with emotional
moments yeah grief that's totally what
it is also in this movie what's really
interesting is that Ellie comes back she
actually talks to her dad like it was
weird like the effect they had
one I kind of everything is Church yeah
yeah and I like that so like but then
like the conversations that they had
creeped me out
and the fact that he was dealing with
the fact that he wanted her back so
badly yeah but this thing didn't feel
quite like his daughter oh I didn't
think so I thought he was trying to
cover it up Oh like I don't know his
whole character just seems so like I
don't know the only time I'm upset is
one that one guy died that kept coming
back for some reason yeah yeah he was
kind of a harbinger always that one
character coming back so that was in the
book too I mean that was like he's like
the harbinger of death he's like he's
like the one at the gate being like I
see what's gonna happen don't come
through here help yeah the image that
keeps coming back to Lewis too and I'm
like I know I just said I'm not a book
versus a movie guy but this is a thing
that happens after gage was hit by the
truck he keeps talking about the
baseball cap full of blood and like how
half of gages head is gone you know and
all this stuff like so when you show me
that she's like unfazed by being run
over by a truck that's my problem
focus on some of this stuff that really
hurts cuz that's what this story is
about baseball cap full of blood is
something that like horror fans would
gravitate I mean and she wasn't wearing
a baseball cap but like something's or
thing that ends yeah it could have been
a really impactful moment and it just it
just kind of felt like oh man that's
such a bummer I do like I do like that
church drew her out though yeah that was
a moment cuz they just originally ran to
the highway because he was a little kid
not paying attention I identified with
that if I just have a lost cat in the
street like goodbye forever right it's
another element of that cemetary like
like exerting its will yeah you know
like the cat will bring the child the
child will bring the mother the mother
will bring the husband yeah I think this
was an effective movie if it hadn't have
been such an effective book maybe
because it would have been designed as
its own thing like I like after the
death I feel like they were hit and
beats too fast and they were beats that
were in the book so if they were weren't
beholden to those beats they might have
been able to and they changed a lot like
I said
right but like they happen too fast then
yeah Stephen King even has gone on
record saying that he thinks that the
changes made were important and made
sense this adaptation absolutely he was
ok with and it's still a downer ending
man because not unhappy
yeah we're not like a Disney Princess
world but if you're gonna go to that sad
of a place we're gonna end it there we
might have hope ended like the bottom of
the barrel I wanted to hold Ike up and
say sometimes dead is better you should
he's gonna be like sometimes Fed is
better you are long look at that long
cat in like movies in general I would
give this a 6 out of 10
but in horror films I would give this an
8 a second really yeah
your disparity between the horror genre
and everything else is that much I wish
either it was more explored in the
family story or it was scarier in like a
scary I want something else that's the
thing though too like a lot of Stephen
King adaptations like people go to them
and they're like it's not scary because
what our culture has decided or current
moment has decided is that jump scares
are what's scary that's fair he's a
novelist there are no jump scares in
novels for sure his stories are about
things that sit in the back of your
brain and make you feel uncomfortable
well I'd stay with you in the night yeah
yeah and like people like real people
people you love people who mean well
going through this okay that's fair
that Stephen King yeah and so when you
from America you know like when you when
you go into that like with a modern
jump-scare expectation and you get a
meditation on grief like boo like he's
gonna lay next to the corpse of his
daughter while she like is creepy at him
yeah my pleasure
all right we'll see you for the next
Stephen King movie whoo yes please thank
you for watching see you next week for
Shazam probably
[Music]